Transcriber: Sümeyye Begüm
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Büyükler sayılara bayılırlar.
Diyelim yeni tanıştığınız bir
arkadaşınızdan bahsettiniz onlara.
Hiç işin aslı ile ilgili
sorular sormazlar.
Örneğin sesi nasıl?
Nasıl oyunlardan hoşlanır?
Kelebek koleksiyonu
yapıyor mu hiç, demezler.
Onun yerine tutar;
kaç yaşında, kaç kardeşi var, babası kaç
para kazanıyor gibi şeyler soruyorlar.
Büyükler böyledir.
Onlara kızmamak lazım.
Diyelim kırmızı kiremitli bir ev gördüm.
Çok güzeldi.
Penceresinde sardunyalar vardı derseniz,
o evi gözlerinin önüne
getiremezler bir türlü
ama “Milyonlarca liralık bir ev gördüm”
deyiverin bir nasıl da güzelmiş diye
yaygarayı koparırlar.
Ama yaşama değer veren ve onun anlamını
anlayan bizler,
aslında sayılara da hiç itibar etmeyiz.
Öyle mi acaba?
Bu satırlar hepimizin çok iyi
bildiği “Küçük Prens”ten.
Çocukluğumdan beri sayılardan nefret ettim
ve matematik mesleğiyle ilgili olan
düşüncem de pek farklı sayılmazdı.
Sayısal hesaplamalardan oluşan sıkıcı,
zor, çetrefilli bir meslek olduğuydu.
Peki, artık gelin
bugün, artık böyle düşünmeyen bir
matematikçinin gözünden
yeniden bakalım bu mevzuya.
İlk olarak sizi pür matematikçi Hardy
ile tanıştırmama izin verin.
Hardy der ki: “Bir matematikçi, bir ressam
ya da bir şair gibi desenler inşa eder.
Onun desenleri diğerlerinden
daha kalıcıysa,
bu fikirlerden oluşmuş olmasındandır.”
Ve yine aynı kişi “Bir Matematikçi’nin
Savunması” adlı kitabında şöyle söyler.
“Profesyonel bir matematikçinin,
matematik hakkında konuşuyor olması
son derece hüzün verici bir olgudur.”
Keza ben şu anda kendimi hiç
hüzün verici hissetmiyorum.
Son derece coşkulu ve heyecanlıyım.
Zannederim yeterince profesyonel
olmamamdan kaynaklanıyor
ve devam eder.
“Devlet adamları, politika yazarlarını;
ressamlar, sanat eleştirmenlerini
şiddetle küçümserler.
Bunun sebebi açıklama, övgü ya da eleştiri
ikinci sınıf beyinlerin işidir,” der.
Çünkü aslolan üretimde kalmaktır.
Aslolan eser üretmek, sahnede durmaktır.
Peki, şöyle düşünüyor olabilirsiniz.
“Bir matematikçi TEDx konuşması yapmadığı
zamanlarda neyle uğraşır?”
Eğer hevesli ve ilerleme amacındaysa
makaleler okur, makaleler üretir
ve bunlar üzerine düşünür elbette
çünkü bilim kümülatif bir şeydir.
Eski var olan bilgilerin üstüne yenilerini
inşa ederek yükseltirsiniz
ve önemli yazınları okuduğunuzda aklınızda
bir takım yeni fikirler oluşmaya başlar.
Bunlar önce gaz ve toz bulutudur.
Daha sonra biraz netleşir
ve vücudu bulurlar
ve bir matematikçinin deyimiyle,
yeni nesnenizin
aksiyomatik yapısını belirlersiniz
Burada karmaşık denklemleri
çözmekten bahsetmiyorum.
Burada bahsettiğim yeni bir matematiksel
nesne ortaya atabilmek
ve bunları belirledikten sonra
bir tanım oluşturursunuz.
Matematikte tanım her şeydir, her şey
tanımla başlar ve ona dayanarak süregider
ve aslolan şey, ortaya attığınız
yeni olgunun
var olan eskileri ile olan ilişkileri
arasında güçlü bağlar kurmaktır.
Eğer bu bağlar güçlü, sade ya da
günümüzün popüler söylemiyle
ne kadar minimalist olursa o kadar güzel,
şahane, estetik bir değer taşır.
Estetikten bahsetmişken.
İşte size estetik bir formül.
Bu bir öğeler formülü.
Öğelerin kendi adını verdiği e sayısı,
hepimizin bildiği bir çemberin çevresinin
çapına oranı olan sabit pi sayısı ve i
kompleks sayısı arasındaki ilişkiyi veren
muhteşem güzellikte ve sadelikteki formül.
18'inci yüzyılda İsviçreli bir
matematikçi de söyler.
Aslında kaderinde papaz olmak vardı
çünkü babası çok önde giden
bir din adamıydı.
Protestan papazıydı ve oğlunu da
bu yönde yetiştirmek istiyordu.
Neyse ki iyi ki aile dostları Bernoulli
ile tanıştı ve matematik eğitimi aldı ve
bu yönde teşvik edildi ve bu sayede fizik,
astronomi, diferansiyel denklemler, cebir,
sayılar teorisi ve daha bir sürüsünü
kapsayan ve şu anda hepsi yayınlansa 80
cildi aşkın yayın elde etti.
Bu kadar
üretken bir matematikçiden bahsediyoruz
ve şu anda Graph Theory yani Çizge
Teorisinin fikir babasıdır.
Bu alan, matematikçilerin ve diğer bilim
dallarında da kendisine çok fazla
uygulama bulan bir alan.
Şimdi neyden bahsediyorum?
Bir çizge deyince ne anlamalıyız?
Aşağı yukarı böyle bir şey.
Noktalar ve onları birleştiren
çizgilerden meydana geliyor.
Biz noktalara birer köşe adı veriyoruz.
Eğer iki köşe arasında bir ilişki varsa
aralarına bir kenar çiziyoruz.
Ortaya böyle bir desen çıkıyor.
Aman ne de minnoş aynı babaannelerimizin
çizdiği oyalar gibi, demeyin.
Bu bir işe yarar.
Ne işe yarar?
Örneğin buradaki noktalar Facebook’tan
alınan bir grup insanı gösterebilir
ve aralarındaki çizgiler de birbirleriyle
arkadaşlık ilişkilerini.
Biz biliyoruz ki ellerinde bu datadan
çok daha fazlası var artık.
Peki şöyle düşünün siz bir
pazarlamacısınız elinizde ürününüz var.
Elbette sınırlı reklam gelirleriniz var
ve bunları en iyi şekilde kullanarak
siz ürünü pazara satmak istiyorsunuz.
Eğer elinizde böyle bir bilgi varsa, o
hâlde ben olsam buraya bakarak
sol tarafta gördüğünüz,
herkesin birbirini tanıdığı
öncelikle o 8 kişiden birini hedef alırım.
Böylece daha hızlı sonuç, daha
hızlı kazanç elde ederim.
Daha uygulamalı, daha gerçek
hayattan bir örnek.
Bu gördüğünüz resim dünya denizaltı
internet kablolar ağı.
Burada arkadaki dünya haritasını
silebilirsiniz ve geriye sadece
çizge teorisiyle çözülecek
bir problem kalır.
Problem şu.
Daha az kabloyla, daha az maliyetle nasıl
daha hızlı bilgi taşıyabilirim?
Peki biz neler yapıyoruz?
Her zaman matematikçilerin yaptığı şey,
dünyanın gerçek problemlerine birebir
çözüm sunmaya odaklı olmaz.
Öncelikle teoriye odaklanırsınız.
Belki yüzyıllar, belki bin yıllar
sonra kendine uygulama alanı bulur.
Bu bizim son yaptığımız
çalışmadan bir kesit.
Buradaki ortak yazarlar Hintli matematikçi
ve Cihat Abdioğlu’na
buradan selam.
Şuradaki birinci graf aynı kümenin
Z12 kümesinin birinci graf.
Kendi tanımımızla ortaya çıkardığı desen
ve diğer ikisi de literatürde var olan
önceki desenler.
Kendimizinki birinci olan daha
sade ve biraz teori açısından bütün
köşelerinin birbirine komşu olması
manasında daha çok anlam ifade ediyor
ve kendimizin olduğu için
daha çok beğeniyoruz.
Şimdi ben şöyle bir yoruma
gitmek istiyorum buradan.
İnsan otuzu geçince bir hâller oluyor.
Daha bir sorgulamaya başlıyor hayatı.
Bilmiyorum herkeste böyle mi?
Buradaki Z 12 kümesi çok
daha sınırlı bir küme.
Ama bu küme benim ya da sizsiniz
ve buradaki farklı tanımlarla,
farklı çizgi tanımlarıyla
3 farklı ihtimali görüyorsunuz.
Buradaki köşeler, bizim hayatımıza dahil
ettiğimiz insanlar, alışkanlıklarımız,
para ya da zaman aktardığımız her şey,
yani tercihlerimiz, aradaki kenarlar ise
onlarla aralarımızdaki
iletişim biçimimiz.
Yani bu desen bizim hayatta
seçtiğimiz yaşam tarzımız.
O hâlde elimizde sonsuz tane seçenek var.
Köşelerimizi ve kenarlarımızı
belirlemek için.
Ancak hayatımız sonlu.
Dikkat edin, çok fazla zamanımız yok.
Bunu görmeyen yoktur.
Apollo Tapınağı’nın girişinde yazan,
milattan önce dördüncü yüzyıla
ait bir yazı.
Biz modern insanlardan
2400 yıl kadar önceye ait:
“Kendini bil”
Ben bu yazıyı şöyle okumak istiyorum.
Kendini tanı, kendini tanımla,
kendi tanımını oluştur.
Ancak bu tanımın öyle kaskatı değişmez,
köklerine sıkı sıkı bağlı olmasın.
Bu tanım organik olsun,
değişime açık olsun
çünkü biliyorsunuz bir nöro
evrim çağındayız.
Yakında sözlü iletişime bile ihtiyaç
duymayacağımız bir çağın yamacındayız.
O hâlde biz de her gün ya da her fırsatta
kendi çizdiğimiz desene bakıp ne kadar
kendime, çevreme, yaşadığım ortama uygun
ve ne kadar olmak istediğim bene yakın
diye düşünmeliyim ve bu yönde köşelerimi
ve kenarlarını değiştirecek cesarete
sahip olmalıyım.
Yeni kaybımız, rahmetli
Doğan Cüceloğlu’nun dediği gibi,
“Kendini değiştirme bilincini canlı tutan,
zahmetine katlanan, çaba veren,
düşünen, hedef koyan,
bilgi edinip öğrenenler geleceğin
mimarları olacaklardır.”
O hâlde biz de kendi desenimizi
değiştirip dönüştürdükçe
gelecek o yönde değişecek.
8 Mart Dünya Emekçi Kadınlar
Gününüz kutlu olsun.
Teşekkür ediyorum.